hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video ich hoffe ihr freut euch alles so
sehr wie ich
wir sind heute mal wieder auf der
website eder produktive unterwegs ich
glaube die website kennt kein schwein
auf dieser website geht es darum dass
wir zwei verschiedene situationen
gezeigt bekommen sage ich mal und wir
müssen uns für eine sache entscheiden
zum beispiel in diesem fall always be
late oder always be an prepaid ihr müsst
uns jetzt selbst fragen hey würden wir
lieber unser leben lang immer zu spät
kommen oder immer unvorbereitet ich muss
einfach die wahrheit sagen ich bin eh
schon immer zu spät von einer clique ich
jetzt hier einfach mal drauf und ich bin
in der mehrheit
allerdings direkt weiter mit der
nächsten entscheidung und zwar entweder
have the bodies der offroad lee also
soll uns jeder einfach im dv den rest
unseres lebens komisch anschauen oder
option nummer zwei heft everyone logwin
discussed
das ist schwierig also soll uns entweder
unser leben lang jeder irgendwie komisch
anschauen wenn wir an ihm vorbeilaufen
oder soll jeder einfach so weg also so
wie ich gerade schon lebe das ist finde
ich ganz ganz schwierig aber ich würde
mich dennoch für das hier entscheiden
ich habe komplett verkackt
also immer wenn ich halt in der
minderheit bin dann muss mir selbst
vergeben und die gerade hat ordentlich
gebrannt hier haben wir nun dass wir
entweder immer wieder von einer hornisse
gestochen werden oder dass wir einmal
von einer hätten spinne gebissen werden
ich glaube ich ihm tatsächlich die
spinne also ihr merkt schon die ganzen
fragen hier sind immer nur so
situationen in denen beide situationen
eigentlich beschützen muss man muss sich
für die weniger beschissene situation
entscheiden das spiel hier kann man
entweder in einer welt leben die von
zombies überrannt wird oder in der welt
von my little pony
wer wird sich denn da für die
eigentlich wäre schon abzuschlachten ich
glaube ich nehme dennoch my little pony
und ich bin auch ganz knapp in der
mehrheit
also da kannst du halt zumindest nicht
sterben
wir müssen wir uns dazwischen
entscheiden dass entweder unsere eltern
umgebracht werden wenn wir zu schauen
oder wir müssen die eltern einer anderen
familie umbringt vor den kindern egal
das ist was ich habe euch oben eine
umfrage reingefallen
da also die genau die gleiche frage da
könnt ihr jetzt selbst war mit abstimmen
würdet ihr lieber dass eure eltern
umgebracht werden und ihr guckt zu oder
dass ihr eltern umbringt und die kinder
von denen schauen zu das sind beides
unfassbar schreckliche vorstellungen ich
mache einfach mit augen zu und jetzt
soll ich hier
nein nein der minderheit
ok weiter geht's hier werden wir uns
entscheiden ob wir entweder tupac leben
retten oder ob wir jesus für zwei
stunden sehen
also
das soll jetzt nicht aber ich würde mich
hier tatsächlich gegen tupac entscheiden
und für jesus und ich bin noch in der
mehrheit
weil ich glaube da will ich mit jesus
reden und sagen hey du kannst du nicht
to back und wieder zurückschicken
wir müssen uns entscheiden ob wir lieber
einen siebenjährigen verprügeln wollen
oder einen 77 jährigen renault steht wer
kommt denn auf solche ideen patrick ist
auch wieder eine übel schreckliche frage
die wir gerade gestellt bekommen
allerdings müssen wir uns ja für eine
möglichkeit entscheiden und ich
entscheide mich für den siebenjährigen
weil ich glaube dass ein siebenjähriger
besser sage ich mal wieder gesund werden
kann als ein 77 jähriger und eine clique
ich da jetzt einfach mal drauf und ich
bin auch deutlich in der mehrheit möchte
ich entweder unfassbar dumm sein aber
mega mega viel glück haben oder ich bin
ein mega krasses genie und habe aber nie
glück
ich bin lieber dumm ehrlich gesagt ja
geil alter jetzt läuft gerade für mich
würde ich lieber herausfinden wollen
dass meine freundin schwanger ist in den
nächsten zehn sekunden also dass sie den
nächsten zehn sekunden raus finde oder
dass ich nie kinder haben kann hier
natürlich dass mein freund schwanger ist
also da bin ich auch klar in der
mehrheit
die nächste frage ist ob ich die
fairways bond oder jason bourne sein
möchte safe james bond safe also jason
bourne alter noch so ne kranke
vergangenheit hin sollte ich will dich
entweder eine zombie attacke haben
wollen sage ich mal oder eine haiattacke
die ich glaube lieber eine zombie
attacke ja ganz klar weil im wasser ist
der hai natürlich voll im vorteil aber
wenn man halt eine zombie attacke hat
dann sind bei wenden wenn die turniertag
im wasser stattfindet sind beide
parteien also ich an der zombie am arsch
und wenn es auf land stattfindet sind
wir haben auch die gleichen bedingungen
versteht was ich meine
hier wird angenommen dass ich 15 jahre
alt bin und zwar würde ich entweder
meine eltern hassen aber ich müsste mit
denen 24 7
derzeit verbringen oder ich würde meine
eltern lieben aber dass sie beide vor
mir sterben hat natürlich das also sorry
lieber habe ich eltern die ich hasse und
die ich überhaupt nicht mag und ich
verbringen die ganze zeit mit denen
anstatt dass sie einfach weg sind und
ich habe sie geliebt so hat also wer
sich darf wenn wir die neunziger
zurückbringen könnten also den style die
musik et cetera
dann ist die frage wie das machen würden
oder ob ich lieber die aktuellen trends
dabei bleiben würde
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich kann mir den 90
er nicht viel anfangen und ich glaube
die meisten von euch auch nicht also ich
bleibe dabei den aktuellen trends war
knapp aber ich hab's geschafft hab schon
lang eine backpfeife mehr bekommen
würdest du entweder nicht reden können
oder nicht laufen können
boah das ist so schwierig wieder
ich glaube nicht laufen
ich glaub reden ist viel viel wichtiger
als laufen für den menschen also not to
be able to walk und bin was was als
200.000 leute drauf geklickt haben
können nicht mehr reden als erster so
will man ja noch zahnschmerzen habe
hätte ich entweder gern 20.000 dollar
juwelen also schmuck et cetera oder
10.000 dollar elektronikartikel
das macht mal wieder komplett keinen
sinn ich würde die 20.000 euro juwelen
nehmen und das einfach verkaufen was
also sorry ich checke wirklich nicht was
sich die leute dabei denken auch ich
könnten 20.000 euro an schmuck haben das
wahrscheinlich sogar noch für mehr geld
verkaufen dann ein paar jahre später
nähe
ich bin lieber 10.000 euro
elektronikartikel und die sinken dann
auch die ganze zeit im wert von liu
windows oder only you use macintosh also
es geht um die software von computern
also entweder von den apple computern
macintosh oder von windows eigentlich
mag ich macintosh lieber wenn ich mich
für eine sache entscheiden müsste dann
würde ich ja auch andere dinge denken
wie beispielsweise zocken und das kannst
du auf mac nicht so richtig also würde
ich zu windows tendieren und bin auch
deutlich in der mehrheit die für
headwear eiglers des jura glass is too
far away oder nie glass is close up also
wenn ich bin eine brille haben müsste
dann würde ich lieber eine brille haben
wollen
die ich bräuchte wenn ich weit weg
schauen möchte oder wenn ich etwas sehen
möchte was nah an mir dran ist
ich glaub ich das ist das ist wieder so
eine verrückte frage wenn ich jetzt mal
ganz weit in die ferne schauen und mir
denke aber das kann ich nicht sehen da
muss ich meine brille aufsetzen also das
ist option nummer eins und option nummer
zwei ist auch das ist so nah da muss
jetzt mal eine brille aufsetzen ich
glaube ich nehme das was weit weg ist
aber das sind so komische fragen das ist
ja genauso wie wenn ich sage hätte die
liebe artikel 13
oder dass youtube weg ist das hätte ich
echt interessante frage also no shit
stellt euch mal vor also wirklich die
hier gerade vor dem bildschirm sitzt
stellt euch mal vor du könntest
entscheiden
möchtest du entweder das artikel 13
kommt und alles zensiert wird oder dass
artikel 13 nicht kommt aber dafür
komplett youtube weg kommt man aber
dennoch auf instagram twitter allen
anderen plattformen das hochladen kann
was man möchte ich finde ich eine sehr
sehr sehr sehr interessante frage also
wenn man sich entscheiden müsste
zwischen einer zensur frei im internet
und auf youtube
noch bleibt das ist interessant das
stimmt mal bitte hier oben habe ich euch
in der umfrage rein wenn ich mal so
darüber nachdenken würde würde ich
entweder wollen dass das komplette
internet zensiert ist und wir ab laut
filter haben et cetera pp oder das ganze
internet es nichts denn sonst bleibt
alles so wie es ist aber youtube ist weg
ich glaube ich würde neben dass youtube
weg ist also klar ich bin youtuber und
das ist mein hauptsächlicher beruf aber
ich glaube wirklich ich würde mich für
das freie internet und gegen youtube
entscheiden
an der stelle wird das heutige wird
jetzt allerdings auch beendet meiner
liegen zuschauer haben die frage jetzt
natürlich mit artikel 13 oder youtube
ist eine sehr komische frage die so nie
gestellt werden würde allerdings wird
mit ihrer ansicht nach wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr doll mal interessieren
was dieses thema angeht also wie viel
ist euch sage ich mal youtube wird und
wie viel ist allgemein ein
ein upload filter freies internet wert
ich bin da echt gespannt
also wenn youtube weg ist es natürlich
auch scheiße ich freue mich darauf jeden
fall auf eure ergebnisse last einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier da
wenn es euch gefallen hat und schreibe
mir bitte auch unten in die kommentare
ob ich vielleicht die tage mal wieder
sims hochladen soll voll viele leute
meinten zu mir luca du musst mal wieder
sims hochladen
ein echt witzig und würde ich vielleicht
eine neue welt anfangen und neu
durchstarten aber jetzt ist ein video
erst mal beenden
[Musik]